I'm Julian and I'm going to talk about
the past 10 years of building open
source standards from parquet Euro to
open lineage so I split that in three
quarter three you know parts and every
time I have like a few lessons learned
about open source what gets uh keep the
community going and so on and so it's
going to be a little bit like the story
and the lessons learned and that's the
important takeaway from the talk so
first the burst of parquet so any of you
remember Apache pig as kind of like
maybe a bit the old technology nowadays
has been replaced by spark mostly for
those use cases but it was my first
contribution to another princess project
and I got the opportunity to go all
through the
um life cycle of going from user to
contributor to commuter to PMC member
and even being the PMC chair for a year
on that project which was really a
learning experience in the Apache
Foundation uh of getting this so it's
like from first using into contributing
it's also around the time that the dry
mode paper came out around 2010 and like
the first you know reading papers as an
engineer is like figuring out what's
going on in the industry
so through that uh that's how I got my
first job my next job like joining
Twitter like there was a big Community
around Pig at the time between Netflix
LinkedIn Twitter Yahoo
and um and so at the time we had a
Hadoop which was you know can store a
lot of data can process a lot of data
but very high latency right you launch
your query you go get coffee and you
come back and get the result and it's
relatively cheap for the volume you can
store and we also add vertica which is
more traditional distributed data
warehouse which as was a much better
interactive experience you get more
interactive queries but at the time it
was not as scalable and much more
expensive and not as stable as well as
Hadoop like depending how you look at it
so there was kind of some trade-off
there was always this chicken and egg
problem of what data goes into vertical
because we can't put all the data
um in it compared to Hadoop add a lot
more data but you know what's not as
convenient to use
so the big question is how can we make
Hadoop more like vertica and so if you
look at Hadoop there's like those two
components they just map produce where
you can like process a lot of the data
in a fairly simple uh problem model and
there's a distributed file system
underneath when you store files and
vertica you have this distributed query
engine that is on top of a columnar
storage so slightly different
abstraction how how is the columnar
storage different from this this rigid
file system and how can we make Hadoop
more like vertica
and so that's where at the time at
Twitter we had this very nice uh paper
reading uh group where we started
reading about papers like what's the
state of the art so vertical already had
there was the original c-store paper and
the vertica paper it explained how that
works what's columnar storage of course
uh reread the Dremel paper at the time
and there was this Monet DB paper as
well which is like foundational on the
victorized execution and how you make
those very fast massively parallel
um engine so you know that got thinking
about how we can do the processing on
top of a do better and thinking about
what is columnar storage how the
columnar layout works right and of
course when you think about the table is
this two-dimensional thing right like
you have rows and column but when it's
stored on disk it is like just putting
bytes after one another so if you have a
raw layout you actually interleaving
data from different columns and if
you're selecting a subset of the columns
you're going to have to redo a few bytes
skip a few by three to three bytes keep
a few bytes and it's kind of interleaved
it doesn't compress very well when in
the column layout the big difference is
you put the entire column at the time
right and so if you're selecting a few
columns you can much more efficiently
access it and you can also much more
efficiently encode the data because if
you have a bunch of integers in your row
you can compact that much better than
you if you interleave different data
types of different
um columns so that's kind of the
underlying tricks to go quickly and so
from this start we started the red Elm
project which has this intersection of
looking at the red Dremel paper looking
at existing file formats that we're
trying to do kind of columnar things
um in this ecosystem and the schema
system we were having using shrift and
Pig at the time and so that got to
starting this project so I just dig out
dug out this first comment from 2012 so
a little a little more than 10 years ago
now and red Elm was an anagram and so
that's like to say that it was pretty
ambitious at the time right like red Elm
was an anagram of Dremel and the like
the idea is like oh we're going to do
the columnar storage we're going to do
the core execution all of it and it's
going to be great like a bit ambitious
but very quickly you know I realized
okay I cannot build like on my own like
this proprietary thing even the file
format I didn't want to build a
proprietary file format that we'd have
to integrate with everything and there
was like way too much work so starting
like I was at Twitter at the time right
starting like talking about it finding
like like-minded people like look it
looks like this is the need like we
can't possibly be the only one thinking
that
um and so you know started saying
um a Wu Health wants to work on the
columnar file format to release of that
and make
um you know the processing on top of
this distributed file system better and
the reason I know there's an error there
is because I use the examples in the
Dremel paper as a unit test in my code
and didn't pass it was like what's going
on I must have a bag somewhere but
there's a bug in the paper
which is cool
um
and so and that's where I joined forces
with the Impala team so the Impala team
at clattera was also prototyping a file
format
and they were already building the
Korean Gene so it was like great we
don't have to reinvent that piece
anymore there's already someone building
this and so we joined forces and we
found the name so now we were scoping
the project to Justified format found a
good name for it and focus on this uh
better compressed
optimized for data retrieval compatible
with the Hadoop ecosystem uh parquet
format so that was the beginning of it
and so on that I put a little timeline
on what the adoption looks like right
from the first commit to getting
together
in 2013 and like others like starting
talking about this other joining like
critio I did The Hive support on my end
I was doing the pig and Swift and a few
other things the integration
the Impala team was building uh Impala
on top like SQL and Hadoop using native
code Generation
Um and then quickly we start seeing
adoption like the Apache drill was
another Sequel and Hadoop project
Netflix also adopted parquet for the
internal storage and the study that I
did Presto support at the time and it
you know quickly you see the the speed
of the project accelerating and getting
more adoption eventually spark SQL built
on top of parquet as their storage
because it made sense right we all
needed this format and so it kind of
made sense and from them you know
nowadays it's kind of everywhere all a
major data warehouses a support Pockets
so I kind of skipping after 2015 and
reaching this inflection point and then
you know like nowadays if I if I
disappear parquet will go on right like
so it's kind of takes a life of its own
and that's like the magic of Open Source
so some of the Lessons Learned along the
way
um so the first thing is ready to make
this successful every contributor
becomes a stakeholder right it's not
just they use the project right or like
the report bag or something right no now
you're part of the project you get a
voice in this you know when when Netflix
starting adopted they became they had
the commuters they became like really
part of owning the project and having a
voice in the decision making process and
how we make Community
really own the project and be able to
drive this and being part of this right
so it's really about making everything
of them have skin in the game and owned
part of it
um a second lesson learned is these
Snowball Effect right so you can see
it's not just you keep pushing uh Rock
up a hill or something right as he's
accelerating is gaining weight it's
gaining momentum it's going faster and
the faster it goes the faster it
accelerates and then really you see this
exponential growth curve and it's really
happening right like it's not like you
need to convince everyone just at once
right it really grows and it takes a
life of its own until it reach reaches
escape velocity and then you know it
goes and does its thing on its own
the other interesting about open source
is they're very very different
definitions of Open Source I think
they're all very fine as long as you
understand right how each project works
and what's the governance so the first
very basic definition of Open Source is
the code is available
but the code can be available you can be
able to read the code and you're not
allowed to use it right that it doesn't
the fact that you can read the code
doesn't give you any right to use it so
that's the first thing is the license
right open source licenses give you the
right to use it so things like Apache
license or MIT licenses are very
permissive the only thing they require
and if you change the code you reuse it
you have to say this explicitly and give
credits to the original project
other licenses will have constraints of
if you have derived
work from that you need to reuse the
same license like GPL and so that's the
first thing right what can you do with
this code second is governance right
because you can have code that is open
source you're free to use it or look at
it but you cannot contribute to it or
you like who's deciding how the code
evolves who accepts changes to the code
so that's the usually an open source
project has a very clear governance on
how decisions are made how you can
contribute to it and contribute is the
thing but to accept contributions as
well and understanding that and the last
aspects is foundations right like when
you have governance on a project someone
owns it someone decides what the
confidence is and someone decides how it
changes how the license of the code
changes so a foundation and it depends
what Foundation but the two big
foundations I have in mind that we're
used to see is on one end the Apache
foundation and the other one uh the
Linux foundation and in particular the
lfai and data which is the sub
foundation of the Linux Foundation that
focuses on data our way to say there's
this independent neutral third party
that is responsible that owns the
project and that makes sure that nobody
can take control of it and make sure
then for example you can have a
commitment that the license is never
going to change and then there's always
going to be some overseeing on how
governance gets changed and the project
exists independently of any company or
any third-party uh owning it so those
elements are really understanding and
it's fine you know depending on its
project it's fine if they're owned by a
company it's fine if the governance is
restrictive or if the license is more
restrictive it's just something you have
to be aware of right like there are
different constraints there are
different rules of the games so don't
use an open source project assuming
something when it's not right but
just some of the aspect of and of course
I think all three of them are very
important when you're doing an open
source standard and you want adoption
and make it part of the industry but not
all projects are like this
so second part of my talk is looking at
the parquet to Aero Evolution and you
notice my timeline on parques stopped
around 2015 I'm going to pick up from
there and talk a bit about the
development of Aero
so in the parquet Community there
started to be discussions about the need
for an in-memory columnar environment
and you say well you have a
non-discaliminal format maybe we should
use that in memory but actually there's
very different trade-offs and if we go
back to uh this money DB example for
example which is talking about
vectorization uh in query engine there's
this need for you know like modern
processors they're not just executing
one query after the other there's a lot
there's a notion of pipelines query
um
instructions execute sequentially
they're split in multiple steps and
there's a lot of cost of branching and
not doing what's coming after so being
able to do the same instruction in a row
many times allows the processor to go a
lot faster and also being much more
localized in memory is using the cache
of the processor a lot faster so there's
a lot of physical characteristic of
modern microprocessors that make it so
that using columnar representation in
memory optimized for fast execution
makes those vectorized engine much
faster which this paper talks about and
that's what drives different trade-offs
from retro uniform disk versus
processing in memory led to the creation
of Arrow
so you know like parquet focuses on the
fast disk retrieval and predicate push
down and arrow is focuses on the fast
in-memory processing and standard
sharing of data
um across things so we kicked off the
aerospec by creating a group in this
leveraging this parquet Community
finding a group of people who actually
needed this kind of standardization
kicking off a spec and starting this
project so what happened
is actually there was an existing in
memory or presentation in the drill
Apache drill open source project that
was very similar to what the need was so
we started from spinning it off as its
own project and that became the the Java
implementation for apacheiro and
starting the C plus plus implementation
making the change that came out of that
group that discussed how we make this
standard for the in-memorial
presentation and then it started kicking
off you see the same adoption curve
because there's this common need and
having the West McKinney which I saw
started the C plus plus implementation
he also drove the C plus implementation
on the parking side
um it gets got in Panda got adopted in
spark there was a lot of interest from
GPU data sharing as well because they
have the similar needs in GPU
and nowadays same thing you see this
adoption this acceleration and it's
adopted in all the major uh warehouses
and I quick notes like duckdb is a hot
things uh I think this year uh and it's
really
like this kind of like use sqlite for
olap or the local mode for your data
warehouse or your beta Big Data fits in
memory and we have the keynote talking
about big big data is dead or it fits in
memory now
um and so you can build on top of your
parquet Aero data and really create this
massively parallel on single machine and
that's very exciting so it's just like
interesting to see the kind of evolution
of going from those distributed
Warehouse back to single machine very
parallel uh so we're kind of going for
circles here
and so the Lessons Learned here in that
case so still building like you know
there's so in parque we kind of stumble
upon on the thing right we kind of oh we
work together and much stronger at two
company driving the thing than one and
then you know a certain company join and
like we are much stronger and then the
the project is much more valuable
because we collaborate right so in Arrow
we kind of bootstrap this if you're
going to want to have this Noble effect
let's start with the snowball as big as
possible at the beginning right because
if you look at an exponential growth
what the very beginning of the
exponential looks awfully flat right and
it grows very slowly so you really want
to get to this inflection point as fast
as possible and then Things become a lot
easier so it's really about
bootstrapping the community with an
initial spec and get this going as fast
as possible
and second it's really important to find
like-minded people who will drive the
vision and because you you know nowadays
you say Oh Park is everywhere so how do
you convince everyone well you don't
start by trying to convince everyone you
start by trying to find the people who
get it will see not just that
weight that it is successful to use it
but they know that because they're going
to use it it's going to be successful
right you start with a few Visionaries
or west and talking about you uh and uh
Ryan blue and uh a few others sorry if
I'm forgetting people
um but 3D kind of Drive the thing
initially and that's that momentum it
convinces the early adopters and then
the early adopters they adopted and that
that more momentum that convinces the
mainstream and then eventually
everything everybody uses it so it's
really important to you you know when
you grow this you don't have to worry
about convincing everyone you just need
to find the people you're going to work
with and we're going to build this
together
and you know someone was telling me uh
oh you're doing open source the right
way like kind of implied the hard way
really kind of like we work with people
like people are so hard to work with
it's true
but you know the kind of cheating in
there right because
some people will tell you it's not about
the destination it's about the journey
right like I'm doing it the right way
the hard way or the right way but the
the cheating part is I'm actually
enjoying this like it's very rewarding
to work with those people build things
together and really to build this
momentum and see it going and you know
in some way I'm telling you you know you
have to do this so that you achieve your
goal but really you know I'm doing this
because I enjoy the process and
eventually I achieve the goals which is
uh you know the chair in top but uh you
really have to enjoy it and like
collaborating and you already get to
work with Incredible people that you
know would not all work in the same
company otherwise anyway and so it's
great to be able to collaborate uh in
that setup
so onwards it's kind of the the next
thing
um I've been working on is the open
lineage aspect we started a few years
ago and again you know like this
timeline the uh Arrow timeline has
stopped like a few years ago and then
you kind of got escape velocity as well
and I'm going to restart from where I
stopped and so same similarly there's a
common need for lineage like
understanding what are all the
Transformations that are happening right
so typically inside a team
people are very good at understanding of
what their practices are in the team
what their what data they read how they
transform it what are their best
practices what they produce but outside
of it well those data sets we're reading
from where are they coming from who
produces them and who do those people
depend on like all of this is very
opaque or like I'm producing this data
set but who's consuming it what are they
doing with it is it like oh you know I
just built this over a weekend and it
was a experiment and now it's being
dependent on for the model that is in
production that's the key Revenue driver
for the company or something and you're
like oh my God I never signed up for
this so happens all the time so
there's very lots of opacity of how
people depend on each other and it's a
problem right because data needs to be
reliable and if you don't understand
what you're depending on it's a problem
and so I've been repurposing you know
there's this Maslow's hierarchy of needs
which is before you reach happiness
before you need to be safe you need to
be fed you need to you know a lot of
basic uh vital needs before you can
actually reach you know happiness and
self-realization of becoming the best
version of yourself same thing in data
right before you can actually get any
value out of it often we are ahead
underwater like oh is the data available
is it up to date is it correct and once
you manage to do all those things then
you say okay now we kind of look at
optimize our business or find new
opportunities and leverage this data and
build new products around it
and a lot of the time we get stuck in
the bottom layer which doesn't bring
value but brings a lot of pain
so that's what led us to start the
markets project so at the time you know
we're at wework uh building the data
platform there and like the big growth
phase of the company
um and the big missing piece in that
data ecosystem was building that map of
all the transformation all the data set
and build a map of everything how your
data gets from one place end to end and
understand how people depend on each
other
and so you know that's how we after
creating Marquez and you know some
turmoil at the company I was working at
um we decided to start datakin which
focused on uh data observability and
really focused like does the data show
up is it correct uh does it show up in
time and is it correct and now part of
astronomer which is really this mission
of delivering data through orchestration
and making sure all your job runs all
the time and giving you the tools to
understand why something is broken when
it's your fault and you know someone
changes schema or something
and so we started Marquez as this
repository for everything
but as we were thinking about it really
the most reusable part of it and the
problem for the industry was the
collection of lineage not necessarily
the the storage right you have multiple
tools and product that could store
lineage and represent it and analyze it
and provide tooling around it but
extracting the lineage of everything
that's happening all your SQL queries or
your spark jobs all your DVD jobs and
all of those things it's really opaque
all the etls and bi tools it's really
opaque how you get the lineage and it's
constant pain to manage this so that
letter led us to start open lineage
as a similar idea right there's a common
way for all those
um metadata storage like governance
tools data observability tools to
collect this metadata and understand
lineage and avoid these n Square problem
like all the data catalog and I'm
putting more pretty examples here in the
open source uh because it's kind of what
I've been leaning towards but of course
that includes also you know proprietary
Solutions commercial tools have the same
problem of having to go on all those
things that transform data and figure
out what they're doing
and so instead of having this a lot of
duplication of lots of communication if
you have a standard representation it
simplifies a lot of the problem because
now everybody speaks the same language
you know same ideas for parquet how your
data is important interoperable between
the various tools you're using and
warehouses
um and now you have a common way of
speaking and it simplifies a lot getting
the lineage emitted available
so open lineage is a spec and it starts
with the spec and of course the
Integrations and you have producers
whether they're transformation of data
quality tools again I put some examples
um of what's covered like some very
popular ways of doing those things you
can collect the open lineage events that
describe the runs of those
transformations
and use them for various use cases
um
and you know they it's not an easier or
you don't have to pick one metadata
system that solves all your problems you
can start having this metadata bus that
sends open lineage event and use
multiple tools uh depending if people
care more about data governance or data
reliability on data quality
and so and restart my YouTube timeline
um so end of
2019 Marcus joined the lfei Indira which
is the you know Sister Foundation to the
cncf and there's a lot of Pilots right
like in the cncf you have kubernetes you
have open Telemetry which is
observability for services and the lfai
and data you have a lot of AI projects
some metadata projects uh like a Munson
is there and there's Marquez and open
lineage was spun off out of markets and
we did a similar thing then with arrow
we reached out to a bunch of people in
this open source ecosystem through the
connection with parquet with Aero and
all of that putting them in a room
virtually like that was pandemic on Zoom
and then talking about what's the
initial spec how do we represent all the
running jobs and make sure we have a
common way to represent it
and bootstrapping this with you know
spark airflow gbt support the like
common open source tools uh getting some
good collaboration with Microsoft The
Edge area and other open source project
um snowflake we had a good discussion
with snowflake there's this no physical
lab support for open lineage Manta which
is a lineage extractor company also
supports open lineage now and a lot of
building momentum like this and now
we're present day right and you've seen
on my timelines it's going to take
another like couple of years and then we
expect your HD escape velocity and keep
growing and open lineage and now
gratitude out of the sandbox in the lfei
and data and we'll keep building more
relationship and more value because
that's how the project becomes more
valuable for everyone
and so if you think of the model and
just putting some elements here for the
good thing about open lineage is like we
can all contribute to make the coverage
better right so the model is fairly
simple you have this notion of job right
a job is a recurring thing that runs
every hour or every day
um and like the typical transformation
you might be running that materialize
the table right and the run is this
notion of identifying each run of that
particular job
and then it has inputs and outputs that
are marked as data sets so there's this
model that uniquely identifies runs jobs
and data sets so that we can stitch
together the lineage and everybody
speaks the same language and identifying
all data sets in the same way and then
you have this notion of facets and each
facet is an individual individual piece
of metadata that can attach to each of
those uh thing and each of them has a
schema that describe this representation
so it gives us a lot of flexibility
in representing metadata so one of the
goals was to not build a big monolithic
spec where you would take forever to
agree on but you have these very simple
core model that describes the lineage
and recurring things and capturing
what's running a bit like we capture
tracing in open Telemetry but the model
is different
um and and then on run that you can
start the community can start defining a
lot of those facets like on the data set
you may care about what the schema of
the data set right so we're capturing
the schema at the time the job is
running so if the schema has changed
from one run to the next you know
exactly what's changed right and you can
start tracking the differences and when
they happen
um you can keep track of Statistics yeah
how many rows were written by this
particular run how many nodes were in
this column at that time and something
like is very valuable for a
troubleshooting problems afterwards on
the job itself you could capture what's
a version of the code right so that the
schema change you can tie it back to
what was the gicha that changed this and
you can troubleshoot and figure out
what's going on on the run you may have
the Query profile how much it costs
right like if you run on your favorite
data warehouse each query will have
metadata attached to it like how many
billable milliseconds on the cluster you
use how many billable scan of megabytes
you use and keeping that in permission
so that becomes very useful uh for
various use cases and it's very flexible
in adding value species of metadata
around that lineage information
and on that so there's two ways you can
add facet one is through the core spec
right so if you go on the GitHub project
you have a course pack each facet is
represented by your Json schema and so
of course you know they can be
contributed here you have all standard
things like data quality metrics uh
schemas column level lineage things like
that which is also very flexible in
enabling people to add custom facets if
they want so all you need to do to make
a custom facet is to respect some prefix
right Define a prefix for your project
for you defining custom facets
and publish on the URL the Json schema
for it and then you can start using it
and that makes it very flexible because
if you want to experiment with something
that's something you don't know yet if
it's worthy of putting in the course
pack and you don't know if you have the
energy to build uh you know consensus
around it you can very much Define Your
Own Thing experiment and then it can be
you know promoted to the course spec
later on
um
to make it more useful so I'll go a
little faster because I have a little
more time than I expected but quickly
um this is just an example of the Python
client on how to Define facet and I'll
send you to more resources on how to do
this and you know if your favorite tool
is not yet covered it's fairly easy to
just add to the tool the description of
what were my input where were my output
and if everybody's publishes their
lineage in the same way it's very
powerful to be able to have your lineage
end-to-end
and the possibilities are endless there
are a lot of use cases around lineage
like everybody wants lineage but then
you have when you dig they all have a
different reason for it and so there's
like the data reliability which we've
been focusing on does the data show up
does it show up on time is it correct
there's a lot of compliance gdpr CCPA
privacy laws uh where is my user private
data going like oh we used to not know
now we need to know and it's much better
that we have to know
um a lot of banking regulation
governance just data cataloging knowing
where the data is coming from you know a
lot of that so I go on the lessons learn
uh quickly on that that's my uh most
important thing you know someone was
telling me Oh you know I've done parquet
before I work on Arrow I know how to
build a community and it's like what
makes you think you can do it again I
was like well you know it's not like I
build a project and I have some Mind
Trick they convince everyone to do it
right it's not how it works at all the
way it works is like oh everybody needs
that thing all it needs is someone to
help pushing the community and it's like
let's solve it together the only way we
are going to solve the lineage problem
in a sustainable way is if we get
together as an industry and we stop like
every part of our project reverse
Engineers every transformation layer and
we keep like running after like you know
headless ducks and trying to figure out
how this has changed it's broken now and
all of that let's stop doing this right
we get together we solve it together so
the trick is you build something people
need right we build it and you're very
collaborative right and that's what the
trick that's what make it work like
everybody needs the thing and being very
open empowering people is like no you're
not a user of the project you're a
stakeholder on the project now you're
part of it you're part of the decision
making process and we're building this
together and open lineage is designed in
a way that we can make all those small
decision in independently right you
don't need everybody to agree in
everything you take the people who care
about data quality you make them Define
the data quality of assets you take the
people who care about governance you
make them uh Define the column level
lineage and and that works very well
right and you just need someone to push
along and help the thing which leads me
to uh my Stone Soup story so there's
this children's book it's a guy who
comes to a a village and is on the tone
square and start hitting a pot of hot
water it puts a stone at the bottom of
it and people come it's like what are
you doing well I'm just doing a stone
soup
which really leads us soup at nothing
it's just hitting water putting nothing
in there and he's saying but you know if
you want to add your own ingredient to
my soup I'd be happy to add it right and
we add it and people come with carrots
or leeks and everybody will add
something makes it better and like
everybody is more incentivized to come
on like this soup is better now I'll
come as well and I want to participate
that's all I'm doing I'm steering the
pot I'm telling people come put your own
ingredients it makes it better
and again you know people are saying
like oh you're boiling the ocean well
well I'm boring the ocean but yeah when
I'm wait a minute because
there's a big Network effect in there
right it's not like oh it's just like no
we're two people or three people and
we're boiling the ocean a little faster
the magic happens when the community
starts talking to each other right so at
the beginning you know I talked to that
warehouse I talked to that data catalog
and you know but eventually they start
talking to each other and then they talk
to other people and then I'm not doing
the selling we're all doing the selling
and this all makes sense no look it
makes sense we need this let's just like
do it together let's not wait for it to
happen like people say like why doesn't
it exist yet well it just didn't exist
because you were not trying to do it
right so here we are so it's just my and
we're out of time but quick summary of
you know people as stakeholders snowball
effects the open sourcing different
shape and size like bootstrap it
collaborate
it's about the connection you build
along the way
and you know just find a need and feel
it allowing incentive and Magic happens
and that's it
foreign
[Music]